hallo und willkommen zu ZDF heute live
die größte türkische Community außerhalb
ihrer Heimat wohnt in Deutschland und
1,5 Millionen sind seit heute aufgerufen
zu wählen sie sollen ihre Stimme für die
Parlaments und Präsidentschaftswahl in
der Türkei abgeben das ist dann noch bis
zum 9 mai möglich
ja und dann am 14 mai entscheiden die
Türkinnen und Türken im Land wer künftig
regieren soll da ist die Rede von einer
Schicksalswahl denn diesmal ist eine
Wiederwahl für den amtierenden
Präsidenten Erdogan keineswegs klare
Sache nach mehr als 20 Jahren an der
Macht und Frank zufolge könnte es einen
knappes Rennen geben zwischen ihm und
seinem Herausforderer Rollo diese Wahl
ist so wichtig weil die Türkei damit vor
allem Scheideweg steht geht's weiter mit
Erdogan oder gibt es ein Neuanfang mit
mehr Demokratie wegen zumindest sein
Herausforderer verspricht schickt uns
Eure Kommentare und eure Fragen die
könnt ihr am besten in die Chats posten
oder ihr schickt uns eine mail ja wir
sprechen heute Abend mit Jana Avenger
vom Zentrum für Türkei Studien und
integrationsforschung wir sprechen mit
Christian Brakel von der
Heinrich-Böll-Stiftung in Istanbul und
wir sprechen mit unserer Reporterin in
Istanbul mit Anna Feist hallo Anna
hallo ja die Gerüchteküche brodelt seit
Präsident Erdogan krankheitsbedingt
Wahlkampftermine abgesagt hat was ist da
los
ja Dienstagabend hat der Präsident ein
eine Live-Schalte oder ein
Live-Interview im türkischen Fernsehen
abbrechen müssen wegen eines Infektes
wegen einer Magen-Darm-Grippe wie später
verkündet wurde er hat daraufhin gestern
sein komplettes Wahlkampfprogramm
unterbrochen er hat pausiert heute
Nachmittag hat er sich zurückgemeldet
allerdings nur online online hat er
zusammen mit dem russischen Präsidenten
Wladimir Putin das erste türkische
Atomkraftwerk eröffnet und was
aufgefallen ist in seiner online Rede er
wirkte müde er wirkte abgeschlagen und
im Vergleich zum russischen Präsidenten
hatte er eine deutlich kürzere Redezeit
wie es nun weitergeht ob er morgen in
Person wie geplant eine Brücke in Adana
eröffnen wird es weiter und klar welche
Auswirkungen könnte das auf die Wahl
haben
das ist zu früh das lässt sich so nicht
sagen allerdings attestieren Beobachter
schon jetzt dass der Wahlkampf insgesamt
von Erdogan seitdem es den Auftakt gab
müder wirkt dass der flacher wirkt als
andere Wahlkämpfe in den vergangenen
Jahren
gleichzeitig ist es aber auch so das
Thema College darulo der Erdogan
Herausforderer wohl besser anzukommen
scheint als erwartet es ist ja ein
älterer Herr den man nachgesagt hat er
wirklich wieder mal schauen ob der die
massenmobilisieren kann aber er scheint
sehr gut anzukommen
Erdogan und seine Herausforderer Rollo
liegen ja in Umfragen ganz eng
beieinander spiegelt sich das auch in
der Stimmung im Land wieder
wir waren letztes Wochenende zu Bayram
zum Zuckerfest unterwegs im
Erdbebengebiet und haben
Wahlkampfveranstaltungen von beiden
begleiten können und bei Kemal College
ist wirklich aufgefallen er hat es
geschafft in AKP Städten also in Städten
die regiert werden von der Partei
Erdogans hat erst geschafft die Massen
auf die Straße zu bringen er war nahbar
er war greifbar die Menschen kamen an
ihnen ran
gleichzeitig haben wir uns einen Tag
später eine Veranstaltung von Erdogan
angeschaut dort war so Männer und Frauen
waren streng getrennt und Erdogan
verfolgt eine andere Strategie er macht
Wahlkampf Geschenke oder er macht
Wahlgeschenke so hat er dort gerade eine
Neubau Siedlung eingeweiht den Menschen
zum Zuckerfest ein Haus nicht geschenkt
sondern zum Mietkauf angeboten aber auch
generell er hat ähm er macht gerade
viele Geschenke er hat zum Beispiel den
Mindestlohn und noch um 100% erhöht er
hat die Mindestrente um 100% erhöht es
gibt jetzt einen Monat Gas gratis und
daneben markiert er den starken Mann
erreist durchs Land und weit gefühlt
jeden Tag ein neues Prestigeprojekt ein
so hat er allein in der letzten Woche
das erste türkische Gasfeld entflammt er
hat heute eben das erste türkische
Atomkraftwerk eingeweiht er hat das
erste türkische E-Auto eingeweiht und
viele weitere solcher großen Projekte
eingeweiht und genau empfangen also
große wahlkampfgeschenke wie du gerade
erzählst aber wenn du mit den Menschen
auf der Straße sprichst was sind deren
große Sorgen große Probleme was erwarten
die von ihrem neuen Präsidenten ganz
egal wer es nun wird
die Menschen auf der Straße treibt die
Inflation rum da geht es insbesondere um
den zwiebelpreis also es klingt ganz
profan aber das Kilo Zwiebeln kostet
mittlerweile 30 Lira da sind umgerechnet
ein Euro 40 vor einem Jahr 2022 kostete
das Kilo Zwiebeln noch drei Lira also um
ein zehnfaches weniger Kemal Kilic da
Rollo hat genau diese Ängste diese Nöte
jetzt in einem Twitter Video was
millionenfach geteilt wurde das wurde
aufgenommen in seiner Küche also ganz
einfach
benutzt um eben mit den Menschen diese
diese Ängste und Sorgen zu thematisieren
und in diesem Video sagt er ganz klar
wählt mich damit die Zwiebel nicht
irgendwann 100 Lira kostet auf diese
Twitter Video werden wir später noch
näher eingehen lieben Dank Anna heißt in
Istanbul mach's gut bis bald tschüss
ja und der amtierende Präsident Erdogan
reagiert seit 20 Jahren in der Türkei
wir haben es vorhin gesagt im Romberg
fast die wichtigsten Stationen zusammen
schafft es Erdogan noch einmal jahrelang
hat er seine Macht ausgebaut der
einstige Bürgermeister Istanbuls
erstmals kommt der 2003 an die Spitze
der türkischen Regierung es folgt ein
pro-europäischer Kurs und ein
Wirtschaftsaufschwung 2007 gewinnt seine
Partei die konservative AKP die absolute
Mehrheit doch es wächst Widerstand gegen
die Regierung und ihren zunehmend
religiösen Kurs gegen die
Gleichschaltung der Medien
2013 schwere Proteste in Istanbul die
Polizei reagiert hat außerdem werden die
Korruptionsvorwürfe gegen die Regierung
lauter 2014 wird Erdogan Präsident und
baut sich einen Palast im
Naturschutzgebiet
ein Putschversuch erschüttert 2016 das
Land Erdogans Antwort Verhaftungen und
Entlassungen es trifft Militärs Richter
Journalisten Lehrer dann stimmt eine
knappe Mehrheit der Türken für eine
Verfassungsänderung der Präsident
bekommt die Macht Richter und Minister
einzusetzen doch die Herausforderungen
wachsen Wirtschaftskrise und Inflation
das Krisenmanagement nach dem schweren
Erdbeben jetzt wird die Opposition ihre
Chance gegen Erdogan ein Bündnis um die
sozialdemokratische CHP kemalster Holo
will der neue Präsident werden
und jetzt begrüße ich Christian Brakel
von der Heinrich-Böll-Stiftung Istanbul
guten Abend guten Abend Herr Brakel wir
haben es gehört die Umfragen sehen einen
ganz knappes Rennen voraus würde man
mittlerweile schon sagen können dass das
System Erdogan möglicherweise am Ende
ist also ob sie am Ende ist oder nicht
das wird sich erst am Wahltag bzw
vielleicht sogar erst zwei Wochen danach
bei der Nachweis zeigen aber was man
sicherlich sagen kann dass das dieses
Regierung die ja eine Zeit lang wirklich
sehr sehr erfolgreich war und auch in
der Türkei sehr viel verändert haben
sehr viel Zuspruch bekommen hat dass die
eigentlich ihre Legitimität verloren hat
schrittweise spätestens ab 2013 ab
diesem Gysi Protesten und das ist ja
eben gerade auch der Grund dass die
Zustimmung geschwunden ist dass viele
Legitimität geschwunden ist dass man
immer mehr darauf setzen musste die
Daumenschrauben anzuziehen und eben
demokratische Rechte einzuschränken weil
man sonst wahrscheinlich schon lange
nicht mehr macht wäre und sie
beschreiben es
in allen entscheidenden Positionen im
Land seine Günstlinge eingesetzt wäre
denn ein echter Politikwechsel unter
diesen Voraussetzungen überhaupt möglich
es wird auf jeden Fall sehr sehr
schwierig und es gibt natürlich auch zu
Recht sowohl Anhänger von Erdogan aber
eben auch andere die natürlich Zweifel
daran anmelden und sagen da habt ihr
eine große Koalition zusammengestellt
und einige der Parteien die da drin sind
das sind jetzt auch nicht so gut meine
Demokraten sondern das sind ja zum Teil
Leute die früher Minister waren in
Erdogans verschiedenen Regierungen aber
ich glaube was ist schon gibt das ist
ein ganz klares Bekenntnis der
Opposition einer Rückkehr zur
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und Sie müssen sich
vorstellen dass wir inzwischen an einem
so tiefen Punkt angelangt sind was
Meinungsfreiheit angeht was
Rechtsstaatlichkeit angeht was
Menschenrechte angeht dass das allein
schon ein sehr sehr großer Schritt wäre
und das auch sehr viel anderes etwa im
wirtschaftlichen Bereich in den
Beziehungen mit Europa verbessern würde
ist natürlich die Frage ob Erdogan eine
Wahl Niederlage überhaupt akzeptieren
würde wir haben eine Frage aus dem Chat
dazu so ob es möglicherweise sogar die
Gefahr eines Bürgerkrieges bei seiner
Abwahl geben könnte also dieses
bürgerkriegsszenario das wird schon sehr
lange an die Wand gemalt ich muss sagen
ich sehe das eigentlich nicht man muss
sagen die Türkei ist zwar ein
autoritärer aber er doch ein relativ
straffer organisierter Start und auch
ein sehr gut organisierter Start in
Teilen auch besser als Deutschland
organisiert muss man auch sagen und ein
Bürgerkrieg könnte es ja eigentlich nur
geben wenn sich die Sicherheitskräfte
wenn sich die Armee ähm da irgendwie auf
eine Seite schlagen würden und das
glaube ich ist aktuell nicht absehbar ob
Erdogan das Ergebnis akzeptieren wird da
sagen die Masse der Türkinnen und Türken
ja auf jeden Fall wir sind ja hier nicht
irgendwie in Ägypten Syrien oder
irgendein anderer Diktatur eine andere
Diktatur
es gibt ein tiefes Vertrauen in das
System ob das gerechtfertigt ist ich
glaube das muss man noch sehen
und da würde ich gerne mal nachhaken wie
frei und wie fair kann diese Wahl
überhaupt ablaufen also wenn wir die
Wahlen und es gab ja einige Wahlen in
den letzten Jahren als als Beispiel
nehmen dann muss man sagen was am
Wahltag passiert das ist größtenteils
nicht unbedingt fair aber es ist
größtenteils frei also die meisten
WählerInnen Wähler können ihre Stimme
abgeben und ihre können ihre Stimme auch
abgeben für den Kandidaten die
Kandidaten ohne dass sie da Repression
fürchten müssen es gibt immer Ausnahmen
das sind besonders ländliche Regionen
sind besonders Regionen in den
kurdischen Gebieten aber das und das ist
ganz wichtig was die Fairness angeht es
ist natürlich nicht fair vor den Wahlen
also Sie haben gerade darüber gesprochen
was Präsident Erdogan alles jetzt
verspricht dann mal geschenkt das kann
er ja nur machen weil er eben diese
staatliche Ressourcen im Hintergrund hat
und das ist natürlich eigentlich völlig
legitim
lassen Sie uns über die Herausforderer
sprechen allen voran Kemal Kilic der
Rollo hinter ihm haben sich sechs
Oppositionsparteien versammelt da gibt
es eine Frage aus dem Chat für welche
politische Richtungen ersteht also
killista und du selber sie haben das
gerade schon angesprochen galt langer
als jetzt nicht besonders ja
charismatischer Mensch galt als
Technokrat aber das ist ja vielleicht
auch gerade das was viele Menschen
aktuell wollen also auch gar nicht so
riesige politische Vision sondern eher
nur ein zurück zu einer Normalisierung
einer wirtschaftlichen Normalisierung
aber eben auch einen Staat in in dem
eben nicht jeder gleich fürchten muss
ins Gefängnis zu kommen wenn er sich mal
ein bisschen kritisch auf Twitter aus
hat
diese Koalition ist natürlich wirklich
sehr sehr breit aufgestellt
würde ich sagen steht in seiner eigenen
Partei für einen Balance Akt
zwischendurch aus taffen Nationalisten
die ist in der dhp gibt in seiner Partei
und er sozialdemokratische angehauchten
Reformen und er hatte den letzten Jahren
sehr gut geschafft das auszubalancieren
aber wie gesagt da kommt einiges an
Herausforderung auf die Opposition zu
sollte sie gewinnen
wir haben es gerade eben hat Anna schon
mal angesprochen da ist ja ein Twitter
Video die Tage viral gegangen da sprach
Kilic der Rollo über sich und seinen
Glauben auch unter anderem das haben
sich 30 Millionen Menschen angeschaut
und manche sehen darin einen
Schlüsselmoment im Wahlkampf da war
sogar vom Obama Moment die Rede und es
ging im Prinzip was den Glauben betrifft
ja darum dass kilage darum nur Alevit
ist was hat es damit auf sich in der
Türkei warum hat er das so explizit
angesprochen also sie wissen ja gerade
im Gegensatz zum Beispiel zu dem wie wir
in Deutschland Erfahrung mit
Nationalismus gemacht hat wo das ja in
die Katastrophe des Holocaust des
Zweiten Weltkrieges geführt hat ist
Nationalismus etwas in der Türkei sehr
positiv besetzt ist weil muss der
Verkehr mal Atatürk aufgrund einer ja
nationalistischen Politik einer
nationalistischen Einigung geschafft hat
die Türkei vor der der Zerschlagung
durch die Kolonialmächte zu bewahren
Teil dieses Deals war aber auch dass man
gesagt hat du bist türkisch jeder der
hier wohnt ist Türke und wir wollen
nichts hören von euren anderen
Identitäten ob ihr jetzt koordin Kurde
seid aber auch nicht ob die andere
Religionen habt das ist uns eigentlich
gar nicht so wichtig
das hat sich dann ein bisschen geändert
gerade unter dem Militär man hat lange
vor allen Dingen islamische sunnitische
islamische mehrheitsreligion bevorzugt
gefördert und gerade die Aleviten galten
immer so ein bisschen als Linke
aufständige sehr viele Aleviten sehr
viele Kurden sind auch alle Viten
deswegen war das lange nicht so ein
Thema und es war halt schon auch etwas
also Minderheiten die man deshalb
zumindest wenn ich klein gehalten hat
das gab es auch zum Teil aber zumindest
nicht thematisiert hat und die auch was
die öffentliche Förderung etwa angeht
für ihre Gebetshäuser nicht die gleichen
Begünstigungen vom Staat genießen wie
das etwa für sunnitisch muslimische
Moscheen der Fall ist und würden Sie
sagen dass es seine Chancen mindert
das hat man lange gesagt also es gab
diesen narrativ dass man gesagt hat ja
alles Kurde oder kurdische Abstammung
zumindest er ist er ist alle Wied das
der so jemand kann da auf gar keinen
Fall Präsident werden aber ich glaube
diese Begeisterung oder nicht die
Begeisterung aber zumindest dass ich so
viele Leute dieses Video angeguckt haben
und dass die Reaktionen darauf auch
nicht so negativ ausgefallen sind wie
viele gedacht haben zeigt eben auch dass
die Türkei ein Land ist was ich rasant
modernisiert hat in den letzten 20
Jahren gerade eben auch unter der
Politik Erdogans also es gibt diese
wirtschaftliche Liberalisierung die
natürlich gerade auch viele von der
viele junge Leute profitiert haben aber
was eben Erdogan und was seine AKP eben
nicht eingefangen bekommen ist das mit
dieser wirtschaftlichen Liberalisierung
eben auch eine Liberalisierung in den
Köpfen der Menschen einige gegangen ist
und das eben viele junge Leute sagen die
Türkei die wir wollen das ist eben eine
Türkei die eben nicht dem entspricht was
ihr euch vorstellt mit einem schon
gewissen zurück zum gestern einem sehr
sehr starken also einem starken
religiösen Bezug und natürlich auch
einen sehr starken
Nationalismus der Nationalismus wird
zwar von vielen weiterhin noch
unterstützt aber man hat schon der also
dahin wo man guckt für viele junge Leute
das ist halt eben weiterhin Westeuropa
hat das eben gesagt dass auch bei ihnen
raus dass die Wirtschaften ganz ganz
großes Thema ist
welches Thema spielt das Erdbeben in
diesem Wahlkampf
also ich glaube das ist mein Eindruck
anna hat das ja gerade ein bisschen
anders beschrieben mein Eindruck war
zuletzt als ich in den Erdbebengebieten
war und auch wenn ich mit Leuten
gesprochen habe das ist nicht ganz so
Wahl entscheidend sein wird wie viele
das gedacht haben im Februar als als
diese Verheerung der Katastrophe
stattgefunden hat
man muss sagen es gibt in der Türkei in
den letzten Jahren auch so einen
gewissen Fatalismus der eingesetzt hat
also ich bin jetzt seit 8 Jahren im Land
und was in diesen acht Jahren alles
passiert ist das wird dir in Deutschland
ja nicht in 50 Jahren und viele
Türkinnen und Türken haben sich deswegen
auch so eine Einstellung zugelegt so gut
also ob ich jetzt im Erdbeben sterbe
oder irgendwie bei einem Terroranschlag
kann ich auch nicht beeinflussen
und was man auch sagen muss dass
natürlich gerade viele Anhänger des
Präsidenten auch durchaus bereit sind
diesen narrativ der Regierung zu glauben
und zu sagen na ja wir haben alles getan
was wir konnten aber bei so einer großen
Katastrophe konnte man auch nicht besser
reagieren was übrigens ein relatives
denen auch durchaus viele in
ternationale Expertinnen und Experten
bestätigen aber ist
also ich glaube es wird eine Auswirkung
geben aber ich glaube es wird nicht Wahl
entscheidend dazu muss man natürlich
auch sagen dass Präsident Erdogan den
Großteil der Medien im Land kontrolliert
und somit eben auch möglicherweise ein
sehr sehr großen Einfluss auf die
öffentliche Meinung hat wir haben eine
Frage aus dem Chat von Ralf welcher der
Kandidaten steht näher zu Europa
ganz klar also wir haben zwar in den
letzten Jahren sie erinnern sich
sicherlich
2017/2016 da gab Sie diese ganz großen
Zerwürfnisse vor allen Dingen auch mit
Deutschland wo dann Merkel als Hitler
bezeichnet wurde und solche Sachen und
wo es auch hier in Deutschland hoch hier
ging was die Türkei angeht das ist
inzwischen nicht mehr so der Fall also
man hat jetzt so eine naja so eine Art
Waffenstillstand geschlossen ohne dass
die Probleme wegen denen ist im Streit
gekommen ist dass die irgendwie aus der
Welt geräumt wurden aber ganz klar wenn
sie sich die Rhetorik des Präsidenten
anhören und auch seiner Verbündeten
nicht nur dass die tiefen
nationalistisch ist das haben sie bei
der Opposition zum Teil auch aber
bestimmt ein Weltbild mit was manchmal
ein bisschen anders von Putin erinnert
nämlich dass der Westen eigentlich
abgehalftert ist moralisch
dass jetzt die Zeit anbricht für für
eine neue Weltordnung und dass die
Türkei natürlich eine wichtige Rolle in
dieser Weltordnung spielen soll und ich
glaube diese ideologische Unterfütterung
die gibt es auf Seiten der Opposition
nicht ganz so stark im Gegenteil sie
sagen ja wir haben auch unsere eigenen
Interessen wir können zum Beispiel nicht
einfach mit Russland brechen wir sind
auf die angewiesen wir können uns auch
nicht einfach nur so an die Europäer und
die die Amerikaner anlehnen und die
Chinesen ausblenden hier immer wichtiger
werden aber ideologisch ganz ganz klar
selbst die Nationalisten selbst die
religiösen in im Lager der Opposition
die gucken nach Europa was die
Orientierung angeht und das macht ja
auch einfach realpolitisch sind weil
über 60% des Außenhandels der Türkei
findet mit der EU statt
ein Satz zu Szenario 1 Erdogan wird
wiedergewählt wie geht es weiter mit der
Türkei
also ich fürchte wenn er noch einen
wiedergewählt wird werden wir ein mehr
vom Gleichen erleben das gibt es immer
mal ab in Downs es wird mal wieder etwas
stabilisierter sein es geht mal etwas
besser voran mit Europa mit den USA es
geht mal wieder etwas schlechter voran
man wird versuchen die verschiedenen
Seiten gegeneinander auszuspielen sowohl
innenpolitische also die verschiedenen
politischen Lage aber eben auch z.B
Russland und und den Westen
es kann durchaus sein dass man sich
wirtschaftspolitisch erholt aber
den den großen Wurf denke ich wird es
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr geben
sollte sollte die Opposition gewählt
werden wird sie vor massiven
Herausforderung stehen gerade
wirtschaftspolitisch es wird
wahrscheinlich eine austeritätsprogramm
folgen müssen die Arbeitslosigkeit wird
in die Höhe gehen und dann kann es
natürlich auch sehr leicht passieren
dass viele Türkinnen und Türken schon in
einem Jahr wenn Kommunalwahlen sind
sagen ach naja vielleicht war die AKP
doch nicht so schlecht also da warten
noch einige spannende Fragen auf uns
absolut und sie haben das Szenario 2
eben das äh killic der Rollo die Wahl
gewinnt auch in ihrer Antwort schon mit
beschrieben vielen Dank dafür und für
ihre anderen Einschätzungen ich wünsche
Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend tschüss
ja lass uns noch mal auf die türkische
Community in Deutschland schauen dazu
spreche ich jetzt gleich mit Gianna
avell vom Zentrum für Türkei Studien und
integrationsforschung vorher hat Delia
Thomas ein paar Zahlen für uns
insgesamt sind rund 61 Millionen
türkische Staatsbürger aufgefordert ein
neues Parlament und auch einen neuen
Präsidenten zu wählen
etwa 3 Millionen Wahlberechtigte leben
nicht in der Türkei sondern in der EU
fast die Hälfte davon in Deutschland
türkische Staatsbürger die in
Deutschland im Wählerverzeichnis
registriert sind können hier ihre Stimme
abgeben von heute an bis zum 9 mai
gewählt wird unter anderem in den
türkischen generalkonsulaten großer
Städte
die Stimmzettel werden dann in die
Türkei gebracht und dort mit ausgezählt
viele Jahre haben die türkischen
Staatsbürger in Deutschland mehrheitlich
Erdogan unterstützt nach aktuellen
Einschätzungen ist das noch immer so
damit kommt den Stimmen aus Deutschland
für Erdogan eine große Bedeutung zu
guten Abend
guten Abend ja ich habe es eingangs
gesagt in Deutschland lebt die größte
türkische Community im außerhalb des
eigenen Landes warum ist das Interesse
an den politischen Verhältnissen in der
Türkei so groß
nun die Türkei ständigen in Deutschland
haben vielfältige transnationale soziale
Beziehungen in die Türkei das sind
Familienverhältnisse berufliche
Verhältnisse zivilgesellschaftliche
Verhältnisse es gibt einen regen
Austausch auch wirtschaftliche
Verhältnisse seitens der Unternehmer
insofern entwickelt beobachten die
Auslands Türken speziell auch die
Deutschen die innenpolitischen
Entwicklung in der Türkei unmittelbar
auch für den Hintergrund der
Globalisierung und der Digitalisierung
sie kriegen empfangen über die
Satelliten über Internet
eins zu eins Informationen so dass das
Interesse nach wie vor vorhanden ist und
entsprechend auch die Hybride Identität
die in Deutschland unter den Migranten
auch deutsche vorhanden ist sind ein mit
einem Grund dafür dass sie dann
weiterhin die Entwicklung in der Türkei
verfolgen wir haben heute bei
Wählerinnen und Wählern nachgefragt und
hören uns ein paar Stimmen an
sie Ruhe in der Türkei haben wollen auf
der Welt da musste er darüber muss in
der Macht bleiben da hat sich sehr viel
modernisiert verändert deshalb wird der
wieder die waren schon gewinnen
eigentlich der Türkei schon was
positives bringen die sind
und
wer möchte keine Erdogan wählen verliert
vor ihm war alles schlecht danach war
alles bis jetzt sehr gut wir finden das
im Moment
dieses System ist nicht ganz
demokratisch
die Vergangenheit hat ja gezeigt dass
die AKP von Präsident Erdogan bei den
türkischen Wählerinnen und Wählern in
Deutschland stark ist zeitweise sogar
stärker war als in der Türkei selbst
wovon gehen sie aus wird das diesmal
wieder so sein und wenn ja warum
also ich gehe davon aus dass die rkp und
auch Erdogan hier wieder die stärkste
Kraft sein werden aber nicht mit einer
Dominanz wie es in der Vergangenheit war
wir hatten 2018 bei den
Präsidentschaftswahlen hatte Erdogan in
Deutschland 65 Prozent geholt und sein
Gegenpart 22 Prozent ich glaube dass der
Abstand dieses Mal deutlich geringer
sein wird und der Grund warum Auslands
Türken Deutsch Türken auch
schwerpunktmäßig die AKP gewählt haben
in der Vergangenheit ist
unterschiedlich es gibt strukturelle
Gründe womit die Türkei über
Ämter auslandsorganisationen auch die
AKP mit ihrer Ausland zu Vertretung hier
unterschiedliche Kanäle hat und die
Bevölkerung hier anzusprechen es gibt
starke bürgerdialoge was ist in der
Vergangenheit nicht so der Fall war es
gibt eine ideologisch politische Nähe
das ist letzten Endes an islamische
Partei und Menschen die religiös sind
und aus dem islamischen konservativen
Milieu in Deutschland stammen fühlen
sich auch ideologisch dieser Partei
zugehörig es gibt
Ausgrenzungserfahrungen mit Einfluss auf
das auf Dazugehörigkeit und auch die
Identitätskonstruktionen von zwei dritt
generationsangehörigen in Deutschland
die hier keine Heimat keine emotionale
Heimat gefunden haben und Erdogan dann
Ihnen diese Boots und als starker Mann
quasi auf der Weltbühne Ihnen auch
ermöglicht stolz auf das Herkunftsland
zu sein und es sind eben ein Konglomerat
an mehreren Faktoren warum die AKP und
Erdogan in Deutschland wählt und
insbesondere auch die Tatsache dass
Auslandstürken die Entwicklungen in der
Türkei das ist ja gerade auch
angeklungen im Beitrag nämlich
Atomkraftwerke E-Autos große
Infrastrukturprojekte und auch die
Vergleiche mit den Vorgängerregierungen
sind Argumente für Menschen in
Deutschland die
AKP zu wählen und auch Erdogan zu wählen
indem sie aber auch gleichzeitig die
Wirtschaftsprobleme die Arbeitslosigkeit
die Rechtsstaatlichkeit demokratischen
Entwicklungen die autoritären Züge des
Präsidenten Ausblenden der schreibt
mobil auf Youtube er hat absolut kein
Verständnis für Menschen die Freiheiten
einer Demokratie genießen können und
gleichzeitig für die Beschneidung und
Schwächung derselben für die Türkei
Erdogan wählen können Sie das Argument
nachvollziehen was sagen sie dazu
nun dieses Argument hören wir immer
wieder also zum einen muss eine starke
Demokratie wie es Deutschland ist auch
solche Fliehkräfte aushalten
zum anderen muss man mit diesen Gruppen
auch tatsächlich auch in ein politischen
Dialog eintreten und auch Diskussionen
starten wie es sein kann eben ein
liberalen Demokratien zu leben und
autoritäre Systeme zu wählen für sie
sind Stabilität wichtiger als Liberale
demokratische Werte das ist zumindest
das was bei den ähm AKP und MHP WLAN
letzten Endes hier rauskommt sind dann
vielleicht zum Teil auch wieder
Integrationsfragen wiederum ganz anderes
Thema es gibt noch eine Frage von Sven
wie sehr sind die Deutschen Türken für
den Ausgang der Wahl denn überhaupt
entscheidend
nun die deutsch-türkischen Stimmen
machen rund 2,3 Prozent unter allen
Wahlberechtigten aus wenn wir davon
ausgehen dass die Wahlbeteiligung
möglicherweise einige Prozentpunkte
höher liegen wird als eine Vergangenheit
nämlich 46 Prozent 2018 ich vermute dass
sie dieses Mal auch an die 50% Marke
kratzen werden
wird sie am Ausgang der absoluten
Ergebnisse keine große Relevanz haben
wohl aber bei der Verteilung der Stimmen
in die Provinzen wenn es darum geht das
Parlament zu besetzen es gibt Wahlkreise
wo die Ergebnisse sehr knapp ausfallen
werden und dort werden die Ausland
stehen die deutschen Stimmen durchaus
eine Rolle spielen in dem eben die
stimmen dann auf die Parteien und
Kandidaten dann verteilt werden und noch
eine Frage aus dem Chat ähm wie sehr
wirkt sich die mangelnde Chance in
Deutschland Wahlkampf zu machen auf die
Wahl aus da müssen wir dazu sagen dass
Wahlkampfauftritte mittlerweile in
Deutschland drei Monate vor der
Abstimmung verboten sind
nun das ist ein ambivalentes noch ein
sehr interessantes
Themenstellung weil
Wahlkampfveranstaltungen in der
Vergangenheit haben letzten Endes sehr
große Wähler mobilisieren können dieses
Mal findet das nicht statt andererseits
ist diese Wahl eine Schicksalswahl was
auch die Menschen im Ausland
mobilisieren wird und die realistische
Chance die dass sie Opposition dieses
Mal tatsächlich auch gewinnen kann wird
die Oppositionsparteien noch mehr
beflüge noch mehr motivieren zur Wahl
ohne zu gehen zu dem haben wir mehr drei
wahlstandorte mehr also in der
Vergangenheit waren es 13
konsulatsbezirke dieses mal sind es noch
drei zusätzliche Bezirke so dass die
Menschen eben mehr Möglichkeiten haben
ihre Stimme abzugehen das heißt es gibt
ein Für und Wieder dass die
Wahlbeteiligung steigt und insbesondere
auch die
Opposition Wähler durch diese
realistische Chance auch motiviert sind
tatsächlich auch diese Hürden zu
überwinden und auch an der war an den
wahren teilzunehmen
letzte Frage an Sie her aber gibt's da
vielleicht auch ein
Generationen gekämpft zwischen der
ersten Generation die hier lebt der
zweiten der dritten wer wen wählen wird
nun es gibt auch in der zweiten und in
der dritten Generation durchaus Wähler
die auch konservative und
nationalistische Parteien wählen
allerdings zeigt sich auch das unter vor
allem gut gebildeteren
drittgenerationsangehörigen das
Interesse zwar sehr vorhanden ist und
die auch aus dem islamischen
konservativen Milieu kommen aber mit der
AKP nichts mehr anfangen können weil
eben die autoritären Züge
Demokratiedefizite
Korruptionsvorwürfe und dergleichen
starke Gründe für diese Gruppe sind sich
entweder von der Partei abzuwenden oder
auch gar nicht zur Wahl zu gehen und
entsprechend die stammen Partei
zurückkultieren ich danke Ihnen sehr für
das Gespräch am 14 mai wissen wir
möglicherweise mehr eventuell geht es
dann noch in die Stichwahl aber dann
sollte eine Entscheidung gefallen sein
vielen Dank einen schönen Abend noch
tschüss
ja und damit machen wir dann auch
Schluss für heute ZDF heute live ein
schönen Abend noch bis bald tschüss